pour y arriver mieux vaut être escorté
dans un véhicule blindé les forces
spéciales de la police d'ov disca
empreinte ce corridor plusieurs fois par
semaine
leur ville est quasiment cerclée au
volant Petrovitch sur les collines les
Russes à moins de 3 km
c'est la seule route ce n'est pas sous
leur contrôle direct mais il y a leur
artillerie vous allez voir par vous-même
les Russes détruisent la ville de
manière méthodique
une telle étoile ils ont besoin de
territoire pas de ville
nous voilà donc avertis une salve de
roquette celle une autre arrivée
pour eux pas question pour autant de
rester aux abris pour témoigner des
destructions qu'ils documents Maxime
nous convient à le suivre
sous les bombes
son quartier général a été détruit il y
a un mois quelques mois nous avons eu
une requête puis une deuxième
a juste frôlé notre base mais à frapper
la crèche à côté
pour son emparer en plus de l'artillerie
depuis plusieurs semaines la ville est
la cible des avions de chasse russe et
des missiles balistiques ça avant
c'était une école les forces
d'occupation russe lancent entre 4 et 12
raids aériens par jour ils ont utilisé
tous leurs missiles des cages 59 des
cages 31 et aussi des missiles de
croisière des S300 et des scanders tous
ceux qui l'ont ils l'ont utilisé ici
depuis le début de l'invasion précis et
technique
il est le premier à sortir à chaque
bombardement pour établir un rapport sur
les dévastations des infrastructures et
les victimes civiles Maxime continue
d'exercer sa mission maintenir l'ordre
dans le chaos d'une ville en ruine
proposée des évacuations et de l'aide
humanitaire aux derniers habitants leur
point de ralliement le seul et unique
magasin de la ville
pour ce qui reste certains ont des
sympathies russes ici l'accueil n'est
pas des plus cordiales Nina 86 ans toute
sa famille en Russie elle fréquente peu
les abris où sont diffusés les
informations
ukrainiennes
j'espère que nous allons être libéré
bientôt
nous souffrons
pourquoi devons-nous endurer cela
fait 10 ans
j'espère que les Russes vont prendre la
ville je suis honnête
j'espère que Dieu va aider la Russie
a été occupé trois mois durant par les
séparatistes prorus avant d'en être
chassé par les forces ukrainiennes
depuis la guerre n'a pas cessé la
capitale du Dombas s'occupait état 12 km
maxime a le devoir de protéger tous ses
concitoyens même ceux qui partagent les
vues de son ennemi
nous avons évacué des gens mais nous
avons des lois ici nous devons les
respecter vivons-nous dans le respect
des lois ou sous la tyrannie nous
suivons la loi dans la ville avant il y
avait 32 000 personnes maintenant 1700
je ne peux pas les forcer à partir et
les évacuer contre leur volonté
même engagement et même dévouement aux
dernières hôpital de la localité à
plusieurs reprises il a été bombardé
l'établissement comptait 170 employés
cessent sont restés médecins infirmière
ambulancier mécanicien pour apporter les
premiers soins et fournir médicament aux
personnes âgées
on a une expression ici mes yeux sont
effrayés mais mes mains continuent de
travailler
j'ai peur j'ai une famille une raison de
vivre j'ai une petite fille de 3 ans
mais mais c'est ma ville notre ville la
meilleure des villes nous espérons que
nous allons tenir et si c'est notre
destin alors c'est notre devoir de tenir
bon
tenir mais pour combien de temps encore
selon la police depuis que la tenaille
s'est resserrée les bombardements russes
sera ont causé la mort de près de 2006
rien que la semaine dernière
nous sommes ici à moins de 10 minutes en
voiture du centre-ville de Donald's la
capitale du Dombas cette région car un
excès Moscou mais dont les troupes non
contrôle que la moitié une position
stratégique qui fait cavda est sur la
ligne de front depuis plus de 8 ans
depuis juillet dernier elle subit les
assauts des forces russes avec la même
stratégie qu'employée à barmouth
encerclé pylonné quitte à conquérir des
ruines